The Chinese government reports that over 100 deaths have occurred...
...as a result of the coronavirus outbreak,...
...with over 4,500 more cases being confirmed in the country...
...and a total of 70 more cases being confirmed by 17 other countries.
In Hungary, three warning shots were fired by a security guard...
...as migrants tried to cross the border between Hungary and Serbia.
The incident occurred at the same location as a 2015 riot by migrants.
In Afghanistan, at least 11 people were left dead...
...after an attack on a police base in the Baghlan province by Taliban militants.
In Syria, the Syrian Army has been spotted patrolling the Idlib suburbs.
The army is seeking to recapture rebel-held territory in the country's northwest.
Finally from France, police and firefighters clashed in Paris today...
...as firefighters in uniform set themselves on fire...
...in an apparent stunt to gain better pay.
As the demonstrations went down a side street riot officers pushed back with tear gas.